[Music]
a couple months ago we played recordings
for you
of chris cuomo of cnn deep in
conversation with convicted felon
sleazeball lawyer michael cohen they
were planning a mafia hit no just
kidding they weren't
but in the did sound a little bit like
they were but they weren't
we verified it in one of those
conversations though chris cuomo did
concede that reporters were bothering
him asking him whether he had sexually
harassed multiple women
i'm always careful when i talk to media
you know right do you know how many
phone calls i've gotten from people at
abc who say that reporters
are calling and lying about things they
heard about me to try to get stories
about me when i was at abc
guys calling and saying i heard he was
the charlie rose of abc
used to invite women to the hotel and
open his uh
bathroom do i look like the kind of guy
who's got to do that
sure why not um but
so i already have a good source that
says that he forced one woman to have
sex i just want to know if you've ever
heard anything like that
there is no woman right there is none
other so here's the problem women who do
work there saying oh yeah you know
some of these men and naming me with
other guys you know we bumped into each
other once in the
elevator and he put his hand on my
shoulder and he made me really
uncomfortable
i mean what the it's it's it's a problem
and now you saw i'm careful with the
media always i've always told you the
media is not your friend
no i want frank bob
and sierra dead i want his family dead
again just kidding
it was not a mafia hit it was sexual
harassment they were talking about chris
cuomo has extensive knowledge of that
the allegations anyway according to that
tape well he's used that knowledge we
now learn to advise his brother the
governor of new york earlier this year
the younger cuomo the cnn one
told us has told his brother not to back
down as
multiple women accused him of sexual
misconduct
now cnn knows about this they've
announced that chris cohen will not face
any discipline
but one of their media reporters or two
of them the creepier one
did say today in his scolding little
tone that everyone at the network was
shocked by the revelations shocked quote
the revelation that cuomo had advised
his brother during strategy sessions has
vex staffers inside cnn
multiple cnn staffers told me they were
bothered by cuomo's conduct
and the violation of traditional
journalistic standards
i guess they didn't notice when chris
comey had his brother on tv
repeatedly it gave him advice on kovitt
joe barelli is a member of the city
council of new york city
he knows a lot about governor cuomo
we're happy to have him on tonight joe
great to see you
now has chris cuomo ever called you
and offered you political advice i'm
just trying to get a sense of the scope
of his backdoor advice-giving
no unlike his interviews with the
governor he actually used to give me
tough questions when i appeared
on his show occasionally and he wasn't
always the most pleasant guy to be
honest
he wasn't so what do you what do you
make of this that his brother andrew
cuomo
your governor the guy who's i hate to
say it wrecking your state
um got advice
may be in office today because a cnn
anchor told him to hang tough in the
face of all those
crazy ladies accusing him of fake sexual
harassment
look tucker why this should raise red
flags is that he's admitted to being
part of the governor's strategy session
and by any objective measurement the
governor's strategy is not to
accept the the investigations and even
apologize to new yorker
instead it's to actually denounce some
of the women it's to lie about nursing
homes it's to cover up his own behavior
and it's to discredit women part of this
strategy was apparently to leak
uh classified not classified but
confidential rather
employment documents on one of cuomo's
own accusers that's the strategy that
chris cuomo
was advising this is a far cry from the
guy who told us all we had to believe
all women
uh he chided us for not believing dr
blasey ford at the time
and this is just not exactly the
strategy that i think a prime time
anchor should be having with the
the governor you gotta admit though
al franken is probably watching this
thinking man these guys are much
tougher than i they are pretty tough i
mean you see so many democratic men
you know all these like self-described
male feminists the second they get
accused of doing something awful i'm
sure it's all true
they you know they they leave but the
cuomo brothers they hang tough actually
they're kind of
giving these women the finger
no it's a double standard i mean it's
double standard for andrew cuomo it's a
double standard for chris cuomo
these are both standards that they
themselves set for other people
uh both when governor cuomo has asked
people to resign and when chris cuomo
has had people on television
they don't live up to their own
standards i'm just glad that finally
governor cuomo is being revealed to be
this this comic book villain
rather than this hero that people like
chris cuomo
and cnn and so many other media outlets
have made him out to be
he's just not that person it's been the
the whisper of albany now for 10 years
and finally it's it's the truth is
coming out
i would be a lot happier if everyone
could just you know drop the
self-righteousness if chris chroma just
said look yeah i mean i'm exactly what i
look like i'm a you know steroid guy
thug it's my brother of course i'm gonna
give him mid-fight you know what i mean
rather than running around doing the
holier-than-thou thing all the time
that's what i find unbearable
i i agree i mean no one would fault
chris cuomo for supporting his brother i
mean
that's what brothers do yeah but to try
to claim that you've been objective or
or
claim that you've actually uh been in
any way unbiased and how you've you've
covered your brother
and then try to say you've treated trump
the same way or other
political adversaries that the cuomos
might have had over over time
i mean it just it's absurd on its face
tucker and i hope the audience their
audience sees it
yeah just drop the falseness and the
self-righteous system we can all get
along
joe barely it's great to see you tonight
thank you for that thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else